para mi presentación voy a utilizar un
dispositivo que es propio de mi oficio
no usa cables no usa pilas
no se conecta a internet
no tengan miedo no es peligroso
de hecho me autorizaron para hacer esto
esta herramienta de trabajo sirve para
decir que yo me voy a quedar acá con
ustedes
y otra herramienta que utilizo es la
palabra y el medio con el que trabajo es
la imaginación yo soy un narrador de
historias
soy un cuentero especial pero la mejor
forma de mostrarles cómo es mi trabajo
es contándoles un cuento le voy a contar
un cuento antiguo un cuento folclórico
japonés
que dice así
había una vez un samurai que se llamaba
kassai el samurai kassai y un día de
samurai casa y regresó a su casa y como
es habitual en los japoneses se sentó
sobre sus talones y de pronto escuchó
una voz que le hablaba desde su interior
y le decía zamora
soy tu alma
encuéntrame
estoy camino al cielo estoy camino al
infierno
[Música]
habla ahí porque mi alma tiene vos tenía
pero el alma del samurai no volvió a
decir nada y el samurai quedó muy
perturbado andaba por los caminos tomaba
a la gente y le decía caminar yo no
sabía qué decirle
y así este samurai fue al norte fue al
sur fue al este fue al oeste y de todo
ese viaje solo encontró la mitad de la
respuesta a su pregunta un monje le dijo
que si he visto tres personas que han
ido al cielo pero una no ha regresado y
la otra no ha traído su lengua y la
tercera está totalmente loca esto no le
sirvió el samurai siguió perturbado
siguió buscando y finalmente la
respuesta la encontró dentro de su
propia mente en un recuerdo recuerdo que
hacía mucho tiempo
un viejo un ermitaño en una cueva lo
había ayudado a esconderse y lo fue
buscar tres montañas yo lo cuento rápido
pero el samurai tardo mucho tiempo y
finalmente llegó hasta la cuerda se
plantó delante de la cueva y ya
al viejo viejo y te acuerdas de mí estoy
buscando el camino del suelo el camino
al infierno viejo estás ahí
y después de un rato apareció el viejo
con la mitad de la cara iluminada y le
dijo
casi me acuerdo de ti
claro que me acuerdo de ti samurai gol
de samurai o lo los samurai flatulencia
dejó en mi cueva tuve que limpiar la
cueva con el hola samu light durante
días enteros para sacarme el olor a
samurai que es cobarde porque es a mulay
se escondió dentro de la cueva del viejo
como un niño se esconde en la falda de
su madre esa mula y koldo oloroso y
copal de y tonto lento samurai inútil
a medida que el viejo iba insultando al
samurai el samurai comenzó a enfurecerse
cada vez más cada vez más hasta que con
la frena hinchada sacó su katana afilada
y en el momento en que estaba blandiendo
la espada para cortarle la cabeza al
viejo el viejo le dijo basta
este es el camino al infierno
y el samurai
quien comprendió el mensaje
volvió a guardar su katana a lo que el
viejo agregó y hasta el camino al cielo
el viejo de la cueva húmeda ese viejo
marco en la imaginación del samurai una
línea como si fuera una pincelada y de
un lado de esa línea quedó el bien la
bondad la comprensión la paz y del otro
lado quedó el infierno la violencia la
guerra a veces como narrador oral yo
también marcó esa línea y otras dejo que
la marca en mis oyentes pero la mayoría
de las veces esa línea se marca sola
parece
solamente un borde
desprolijo por cierto pero es mucho más
que eso lo que está del otro lado del
borde lo que está del otro lado de la
línea es lo marginal y aquello que es
marginal nos es desconocido y lo
desconocido nos transforma en ignorantes
y la ignorancia alimenta al miedo
y frente al miedo o huimos o atacamos
oímos o atacamos y esto es algo que le
sucede a los que están de un lado del
borde y del otro lado del borde también
mi especialidad como narrador oral es ir
a contar cuentos del otro lado de la
línea que marcó el viejo yo cuento mitos
leyendas relatos anécdotas historias en
cárceles en villas en hospitales en
basurales pero también lo hago en
escuelas en bares y en teatros y cuando
cuento cuentos recibo respuestas observo
transformaciones
cuando cuento cuentos la violencia queda
afuera las armas quedan afuera y aparece
la persona la persona queda adentro y
con ella queda dentro su esperanza
la unidad número 48 es una cárcel de
máxima seguridad ahí adentro funciona
una universidad la universidad nacional
de san martín y en ese contexto yo
coordino un taller un taller para
inventar y para contar historias este es
un ejemplo de cómo la esperanza queda
adentro
yo soy martín horacio bustamante estoy
en la unidad 48 de la calle san martín
me encontré con esto que me pareció
maravilloso porque me puse a pensar que
me contó un cuento a mí
y me pregunte si yo le conté algún
cuento a mis hijos y yo no le contienen
en cuenta a mis hijos y me género algo
dentro que no que no puedo expresarlo
con palabras
que no se puede expresar y le conté un
cuento a mi hija como te conté vino a
visitar a mi hija le contó un cuento a
mi hija que yo no me olvido nunca más la
cara que
con que me miraba no creo que quedó
grabado y viste que hay momentos que
hubo con tus hijos buscas esos momentos
esas caras esos a esas muecas que te que
se te este grave en la foto que se te
graben
tengo 800 fotos sería ver vivir a cara
de cómo me miraba como abría los ojos de
cómo y como los gestos y después miró a
la madre y con los ojos llenos de
lágrimas que se le cayó una lágrima
víctima una ternura terrible no pero ahí
me di cuenta yo que luego no tantos años
pasaron y yo no recién hoy aprendo a
contar un cuento a mi hijo
después de ese día
después de ese día martín volvió a su
celda después de la visita
y su hija volvió a su casa donde no está
a martín su papá sin embargo hay
recuerdos que perduran por siempre yo no
sé si la vida de martín va a cambiar
contundentemente o no pero ese instante
fue reparador el arte une y repara y la
narración oral es un arte antiguo es
como dar una puntada con aguja e hilo
es muy posible que la tela que el tejido
no se vuelva a unir por un solo punto
pero si cada uno de nosotros fuera del
otro lado de la línea y diera una
puntada el tejido social se vuelve a
unir es muy posible que no quede como
antes
va a haber marcas va a haber recuerdos
va a haber desconfianza pero va a estar
unido
mientras que esté separado haber
diferencias y las diferencias generan
violencia y el sistema responde a esa
violencia con más violencia
multiplicando la replicando la
narrar y escuchar historias es reparador
las historias nos tienden puentes lazos
de forma amable las historias desde hace
miles de años nos enseñan nos muestran
que la vida se puede manejar de
diferentes formas frente a una misma
situación los cuentos nos devuelven la
esperanza en porciones pequeñas
porciones fáciles de administrar y es
algo que cualquiera de nosotros puede
hacer porque es parte de nuestra
humanidad
además
quiero decirles algo sobre
esta tecnología
y sobre el miedo
hace unos minutos cuando llegué a aquí y
abrí la silla o cuando la abro en una
cárcel o labró en una escuela yo no sé
para qué va a terminar usándose sí para
escucharnos o para golpearnos pero eso
eso de no saber lo que va a pasar eso
eso no es el miedo
el miedo
el miedo es no animarse a abrir la silla
en ningún lado eso es el miedo
[Aplausos]